I work with this guy Roger love is
incredible we worked tirelessly and so I
called him and said back in LA on the
15th of February and hopefully I can do
it in just six days Bradley Cooper and
Lady gaga will perform their nominated
song shallow on the Oscar stage now it's
already an odds-on favorite to take home
the award for best song so we figured we
would like to honor them by flashing
back to when we first met Gaga and
Bradley we actually have your very first
interview that you did really what year
was that one for $2,000 for Elias yeah
good memory
Sheryl's alias I'm totally totally blown
away it's hot sexy it's pumping it's
from the frosted tips to the cream color
to suit Bradley has come a long way
since that very first et interview new
life Bradley's first TV appearance was
in a 1999 episode of Sex in the City he
was everything I was looking for that
night single straight and the smoker two
years later he landed his first film
role in the indie cult comedy wet hot
American summer we'll meet again and
we'll see what kind of people we've
blossomed into I just graduated school
today's before I came out here so having
the opportunity to work on a film was
something I would jump at 2009 the
hangover would ultimately make Cooper a
household name
the night will never forget
I just say yeah yeah seven Oscar
nominations and one sexiest man alive
cover later it's hard to believe he
wasn't always thought of as a handsome
leading man
the feedback was you're not really you
have to fix again it's definitely not
for everybody and I've heard everything
everything back in 2009 was Gaga's first
et interview what's it like to all of a
sudden look up and say I'm the hottest
act in the world
I don't think of myself that way you
know it doesn't matter if I'm number one
now I want to be number one for the next
two year in the year since she didn't
just Teeter on the edge of glory she
surpassed it on her terms
I don't like fake people I like it
straight up down the mill and I'm from
New York I can smell them from a mile
away
before telling 31 million albums
worldwide and making the phrase meat
dress a thing she was just a little
extra chasing her dreams in a 2001
episode of The Sopranos Gaga got her
first TV credit as girl at swimming pool
number two in 2005 she was served a
dirty salad on the MTV prank show
boiling points three years later and
almost famous Gaga even made a cameo on
the hills it is like an intense texture
in 2016 she won her first Golden Globe
for her role in American Horror Story I
never imagined any of this this is truly
magnificent now just call her leading
Lady Gaga with her double Oscar
nominations for a star's born
but can you believe in 2011 she told ET
acting just wasn't her thing like to act
in my videos but I I'm not an actress or
I'm a musician so I'm a musician right
now yes come back with me like you told
me you want gonna be but once you go buy
a ticket